demain 15 août l'assomption c'est la
fête de la sainte vierge des processions
sont organisés dans tout paris point
d'orgue de cette journée un récital sera
donnée vers 20 heures sous les voûtes de
notre-dame cérémonie également au
sacré-coeur à montmartre seront célébrés
de nombreux offices le sacré-coeur haut
lieu touristique se gère véritablement
comme une entreprise et près de 70
personnes travaillent à longueur d'année
marie pierre cau tellement égayent krief
ont pu ainsi pénétrer dans le secret des
dieux 25 ans de travail petites mains
pour une cause
le sacré coeur et les chasubles des
traîtres la passion pour une ambiance
une maison avant même la fois c'est
comme si j'étais chez moi et quand je
termine pas ici le fait que le termine à
la maison vous êtes prononce oui je suis
pas la donne pas à me caler à l'acte
alors qu'il a joué
oh
dans l'église depuis plus de 100 ans ont
pris ce sont les 1200 adorateurs ils se
relaient 24 heures sur 24 devant le
coeur du christ symbole de la passion
l'adoration ça veut dire rendre grâce à
dieu pour la vie pour les bienfaits de
ce monde
demandez à dieu un certain nombre de
choses en précisant que notre rôle c'est
d'essayer d'évangéliser toute prière et
la prière fondamentalement chrétienne
c'est pas de faire plier la volonté de
dieu à notre désir ou à notre demande si
légitime puisqu'elle permet mais le fond
de la prière chrétienne c'est que la
volonté libre de l'homme se coordonnent
où se coule
si vous voulez dans la volonté de dieu
adoré cela suppose aussi gérer même par
l'informatique
le principe du sacré coeur l'adoration
perpétuelle
chaque jour chaque heure chaque minute
mais le sacré coeur c'est aussi ces deux
boutiques installées au coeur même de
l'église
le chiffre d'affaires est un secret bien
gardé puisqu'il paraît que le problème
est ailleurs
c'est bien que tout ce qu'on fait est
qu'ils doivent être autour de la
basilique n'est pas n'est pas rentable
il faut bien que quelque part ce soit ça
soit financé la finance c'est son métier
pierre estrade hors de la chaussée son
diplôme il l'a mis à la disposition de
l'église
l'entreprise butséle augmenter les
ventes de cette fois des cravates pièces
détachées ou d'augmenter les bénéfices
de l'entreprise ça n'a rien de
répréhensible en soi
posez pas très exaltant veut dire prenez
la motivation confondent
c'est quand même un peu sec tandis que
de travailler ici au sacré coeur ça
donne une autre dimension et des
mentions profonde qui est dimension
spirituelle
puis vous avez l'intérêt du travail
l'intérêt du travail géré par exemple la
bonne marche de les fremm une
association dépendante du sacré coeur
qui accueille toute l'année des
congressistes comme ici la cftc logement
et même salle de travail infrastructure
très structurée autour d'une mission ça
m'a envoyé un coin grâce pour moi
guingois ce moment parce qu'on
commençait catholique en s'écoutant
c'est toute ma famille j'en n'ai pas de
famille car c'est une femme
la basilique du sacré-coeur à une école
de la primaire à la terminale
la maîtrise de montmartre une
caractéristique huit heures de cours et
de chant par semaine et sur lui dans
cette école parce que je la prends une
chanson spécialement et avoir des
connaissances au niveau
comment ce père y est on connaît trop
dur les élèves qui sont en fait
tablissements accepte d'emblée à
l'inscription de participer à toutes les
grandes fêtes de la basilique du
sacré-coeur soit pas chant choral soit
parlée au service de la messe
ils sont donc 80 employés salariés plus
les bénévoles de la sacristie jusqu'à la
gestion du bureau des pèlerinages
on se sent portée voilà qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire par là vous décrire un
peu plus c'est à dire que l'on n'a pas
ces moments de découragement comme on a
beau s'y sont l'extérieur l'extérieur de
la basilique et ses vendeurs ambulants
africains clandestins et musulmans mais
cela c'est déjà une autre histoire